in the mid 90s the cdc and kaiser
permanente
discovered an exposure that dramatically
increased the risk
for 7 out of 10 of the leading causes of
death in the united states
in high doses it affects brain
development
the immune system
hormonal systems and even the way our
dna is read and transcribed
folks who are exposed in very high doses
have triple the lifetime risk of heart
disease and lung cancer
and a 20 year difference in life
expectancy
and yet doctors today are not trained in
routine screening or
treatment now the exposure i'm talking
about is not a pesticide
or packaging chemical
it's childhood trauma
okay what kind of trauma am i talking
about here i'm not talking about failing
a test or losing a basketball game i am
talking about threats that are so severe
or pervasive that they literally get
under our skin and change our physiology
things like abuse or neglect or growing
up with a parent who struggles with
mental illness or substance dependence
now for a long time i view these things
in the way i was trained to view them
either as a social problem refer to
social services
or as a mental health problem
refer to mental health services
and then something happened to make me
rethink my entire approach
when i finished my residency i wanted to
go someplace where i felt really needed
some place where i could make a
difference
so i came to work for california pacific
medical center one of the best private
hospitals in northern california
and together we opened a clinic in
bayview hunters point one of the poorest
most underserved neighborhoods in san
francisco
now prior to that point
there had been only one pediatrician in
all of bayview to serve more than 10
000 children so we hung a shingle and we
were able to provide top quality care
regardless of ability to pay it was so
cool we targeted the typical health
disparities access to care immunization
rates asthma hospitalization rates
and we hit all of our numbers we felt
very proud of ourselves
but then i started noticing a disturbing
trend
a lot of kids were being referred to me
for adhd or attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder
but when i actually did a thorough
history and physical
what i found was that for most of my
patients i couldn't make a diagnosis of
adhd
most of the kids i was seeing had
experienced such severe trauma
that
it felt like something else was going on
somehow
i was missing something important
now before i did my residency i did a
master's degree in public health and one
of the things that they teach you in
public health school is that if you're a
doctor and you see a hundred kids that
all drink from the same well
and 98 of them develop diarrhea
you can go ahead and write that
prescription for dose after dose after
dose of antibiotics
or you can walk over and say what the
hell is in this well
so i began reading everything that i
could get my hands on about how exposure
to adversity affects the developing
brains and bodies of children and then
one day
my colleague walked into my office and
he said
dr burke have you seen this
in his hand was a copy of a research
study called the adverse childhood
experiences study
that day
changed my clinical practice
and ultimately
my career
the adverse childhood experiences study
is something that everybody needs to
know about it was done by dr vince
felitti at kaiser and dr bob onda at the
cdc and together
they asked 17 and a half thousand adults
about their history of exposure to what
they called adverse childhood
experiences or aces
those include physical emotional or
sexual abuse physical or emotional
neglect parental mental illness
substance dependence incarceration
parental separation or divorce
or domestic violence
for every yes you would get a point on
your a score
and then what they did was they
correlated these ace scores against
health outcomes
what they found
was striking
two things number one
aces are incredibly common
67
of the population had at least one ace
and 12.6 percent one in eight
had four or more aces
the second thing that they found was
that there was a dose response
relationship
between aces
and health outcomes
the higher your ace score the worse your
health outcomes for a person with an a
score or four or more their relative
risk of chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease was two and a half times that of
someone with an a score of zero
for hepatitis it was also two and a half
times for depression it was four and a
half times for suicidality it was 12
times
a person with an a score of seven or
more had triple the lifetime risk of
lung cancer
and three and a half times the risk of
ischemic heart disease the number one
killer in the united states of america
well of course
this makes sense you know
some people looked at this data and they
said come on
you know you have a rough childhood
you're more likely to drink and smoke
and do all these things that are going
to ruin your health this isn't science
this is just bad behavior
it turns out this is exactly
where the science comes in
we now understand better than we ever
have before
how
exposure to early adversity affects the
developing brains and bodies of children
it affects areas like the nucleus
accumbens the pleasure and reward center
of the brain that is implicated in
substance dependence
it inhibits the prefrontal cortex which
is necessary for impulse control and
executive function a critical area for
learning and on mri scans we see
measurable differences in the amygdala
the brain's fear response center
so there are real
neurologic reasons why folks exposed to
high doses of adversity are more likely
to engage in high-risk behavior and
that's important to know but it turns
out that even if you don't engage in any
high-risk behavior you're still more
likely
to develop heart disease or cancer
the reason for this has to do with the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis the
brains and body stress response system
that governs our fight or flight
response
how does it work
well imagine you're walking in the
forest and you see a bear
immediately your hypothalamus sends a
signal to your pituitary would send a
signal to your adrenal gland that says
release stress hormones adrenaline
cortisol
and so your heart starts to pound your
pupils dilate your airways open up and
you are ready
to either fight that bear
or run from the bear
and that is wonderful
if you're in a forest
and there's a bear
but the problem
is what happens when the bear comes home
every night
and this system is activated over
and over and over again
and it goes from being adaptive or
life-saving
to maladaptive or health damaging
children are especially sensitive to
this repeated stress activation because
their brains and bodies are just
developing
high doses of adversity not only affect
brain structure and function
they affect the developing immune system
developing hormonal systems and even the
way our dna is read and transcribed
so for me
this information through my old training
out the window because when we
understand the mechanism of a disease
when we know not only which pathways are
disrupted but how
then as doctors
it is our job to use this science
for prevention and treatment that's what
we do
so in san francisco we created the
center for youth wellness to prevent
screen and heal the impacts of aces and
toxic stress
we started simply with routine screening
of every one of our kids at their
regular physical because i know
that if my patient has an a score of
four
she's two and a half times as likely to
develop hepatitis or copd she's four and
a half times as likely to become
depressed and she's 12 times as likely
to attempt to take her own life
as my patient with zero aces i know that
when she's in my exam room for our
patients who do screen positive we have
a multi-disciplinary treatment team that
works to reduce the dose of adversity
and treat symptoms using best practices
including home visits
care coordination
mental health care nutrition
holistic interventions and yes
medication when necessary
but we also educate parents about the
impact of aces and toxic stress the same
way you would for covering electrical
outlets or lead poisoning
and we tailor the care of our asthmatics
and our diabetics in a way that
recognizes that they may need more
aggressive treatment given the changes
to their hormonal and immune systems
so the other thing that happens
when you understand this science is that
you want to shout it from the rooftops
because this isn't just an issue for
kids in bayview
i figured the minute that everybody else
heard about this it would be routine
screening
multi-disciplinary treatment teams and
it would be a race to the most effective
clinical treatment protocols
yeah that did not happen
and that was a huge learning for me
what i had thought of as simply
best clinical practice
i now
understand
to be a movement
in the words of dr robert block the
former president of the american academy
of pediatrics
adverse childhood experiences
are the single
greatest
unaddressed public health threat facing
our nation today
and for a lot of people
that's a terrifying prospect
the scope and scale of the problem seems
so large that it feels overwhelming to
think about how we might approach it
but for me
that's actually where the hope lies
because when we have the right framework
when we
recognize this to be a public health
crisis
then we can begin to use the right
toolkit to come up with solutions
from tobacco to lead poisoning to hiv
aids the united states actually has
quite a strong track record with
addressing public health problems
but replicating those successes
with aces and toxic stress
is going to take determination and
commitment
and when i look at what our nation's
response has been so far
i wonder
why haven't we taken this more seriously
you know at first
i thought that we marginalized the issue
because it doesn't apply to us right
that's an issue for those kids in those
neighborhoods which is weird because the
data doesn't bear that out
the original aces study was done in a
population that was 70 caucasian
70 college educated
but then
the more i talk to folks
i'm beginning to think that maybe i had
it completely backwards
if i were to ask
how many people in this room
grew up with a family member
who suffered from mental illness
i bet a few hands would go up
and then if i were to ask how many folks
had a parent who maybe drank too much or
who really believe that if you spare the
rod you spoil the child
i bet a few more hands would go up
even in this room
this is an issue that touches many of us
and i'm beginning to believe that we
marginalize the issue because it does
apply to us
maybe it's easier to see in other zip
codes because we don't want to look at
it
we'd rather be sick
fortunately
scientific advances and frankly economic
realities
make that option less viable every day
the science is clear
early adversity dramatically affects
health across a lifetime
today we are beginning to understand how
to interrupt the progression
from early adversity to disease and
early death
and 30 years from now
the child who has a high a score and
whose behavioral symptoms go
unrecognized
whose asthma management is not connected
and who goes on to develop high blood
pressure and early heart disease or
cancer
will be just as anomalous as a six-month
mortality from hiv aids people will look
at that situation and say what the heck
happened there
this is treatable
this is
beatable
the single most important thing
that we need today
is the courage to look this problem in
the face
and say this is real and this is
all of us
i believe
that we
are the movement
thank you
[Applause]